witaj ponownie w Quantum Computing w praktyce, jestem Olivia Lan i dzisiejszy odcinek trzeci skupi się na
eksperymencie qaoa w skali użytkowej jeśli byłeś z nami od początku, widziałeś jak omawialiśmy
sprzęt IBM Quantum, framework wzorców Qiskit oraz najnowsze i najlepsze techniki mitygacji błędów, które
badacze i deweloperzy stosują do skalowania Quantum circuits uważaliśmy, że naprawdę ważne jest, żebyś miał cały ten
kontekst i żebyśmy pokazali ci kierunek, w którym zmierzamy, ale teraz nie ma powodu, żeby dłużej czekać na zobaczenie tych wszystkich informacji w
działaniu teraz kilka rzeczy, które warto mieć na uwadze zanim zaczniemy, wszystko będzie podążać za frameworkiem wzorców Qiskit
przejdziemy przez te kroki po kolei: numer jeden to mapowanie problemu, dwa — optymalizacja circuit, trzy —
wykonanie z Primitives i cztery — postprocessing, czyli analiza wyników zaczniemy od dość małego przykładu,
żebyś mógł jak najlepiej zrozumieć te kroki i ich cel następnie omówimy bardzo podobny, ale znacznie
większy przykład, aby pokazać jak można skalować problem do poziomu 100 qubitów dam ci wszystkie
narzędzia, które pozwolą ci po tym wykładzie samodzielnie uruchomić ten problem na koniec — to nie będzie
szczegółowe omówienie kodu, niezależnie od tego jak bardzo się staramy, wraz z postępem kod się starzeje i staje się przestarzały, więc jeśli będziesz
oglądać ten film rok po jego premierze, nie chcę żebyś skupiał się na składni, która może się nieco zmieniać z czasem, zamiast tego będzie to
szczegółowa dyskusja logiki i sformułowania problemu, jednak istnieje samouczek w notebooku dołączony do tego
wideo, który jest podlinkowany w opisie poniżej śledzenie kodu lub korzystanie z niego po obejrzeniu
tej lekcji i samodzielne uruchomienie go da ci najlepsze możliwe doświadczenie edukacyjne, więc jako krótkie przypomnienie — nie
wszystkie problemy obliczeniowe nadają się do Quantum Computing łatwe problemy i proste obliczenia nie muszą
korzystać z tej technologii, ponieważ klasyczne komputery są już doskonale przystosowane do ich rozwiązywania od 2024 roku
trzy dziedziny, co do których jesteśmy najbardziej optymistycznie nastawieni to: symulowanie natury, przetwarzanie danych o złożonej
strukturze i wreszcie optymalizacja — problemy optymalizacyjne to jedne z najtrudniejszych obliczeniowo
problemów do efektywnego rozwiązania w problemie optymalizacyjnym szukasz jak największej lub jak najmniejszej wartości
dla danej funkcji kosztu jednak dla wielu interesujących problemów znalezienie tego ekstremum staje się wykładniczo trudniejsze
wraz z rozmiarem problemu dlatego tak trudno go obliczyć na przykład możesz sobie wyobrazić jak
trudne może być obliczenie optymalnych tras lotów lub tras dostaw w całym kraju w tej lekcji będziemy
badać konkretny problem optymalizacyjny zwany Max cut, który będziemy rozwiązywać za pomocą Quantum
algorytmu zwanego quantum approximation optimization algorithm czyli qaoa czym więc jest problem Max cut?
problem maksymalnego cięcia to rodzaj kombinatorycznego problemu optymalizacyjnego zdefiniowanego na grafie, gdzie celem jest
podział wierzchołków grafu na dwa podzbiory tak, aby liczba krawędzi między tymi dwoma podzbiorami była
zmaksymalizowana, więc na przykład w tym grafie każdy węzeł jest połączony w ten sposób, a Max cut jest pokazany przez tę falistą
linię, która dzieli węzły na grupę fioletową i szarą sposób na to, aby przejść przez jak największą
liczbę krawędzi to przecięcie pięciu krawędzi ponieważ ten graf jest tak mały,
nie jest trudno wypróbować kilka możliwych cięć na papierze lub nawet w głowie i ustalić, że pięć to najlepsza możliwa
opcja ale wyobraź sobie, że liczba węzłów podwoiła się, a potem potroiła — szybko staje się to niemożliwe do zrobienia
ręcznie i po pewnej liczbie staje się tak trudne, że nawet superkomputery mają problem z niezawodnym zwróceniem najlepszej odpowiedzi, ponieważ
maksymalna liczba cięć skaluje się wykładniczo z liczbą węzłów podczas gdy może to wydawać się nieco abstrakcyjne,
istnieje wiele rzeczywistych problemów, które można sformułować jako problem Max cut, takich jak wykrywanie oszustw w finansach, klastrowanie grafów,
projektowanie sieci, projektowanie VLSI, a także analiza mediów społecznościowych
przykład z mediami społecznościowymi jest szczególnie łatwy do zrozumienia — powiedzmy, że chcesz znaleźć grupę osób, które mają jak najwięcej
połączeń z innymi osobami na platformie mediów społecznościowych, aby zidentyfikować power users lub osoby, które mają
największy wpływ w grupie firmy faktycznie próbują to robić całkiem często, jeszcze jedna uwaga — Max cut jest często
podprogramem większego problemu, więc może nie definiować samej aplikacji, ale być używany pod spodem, jest to
o wiele bardziej powszechne niż mogłoby się naiwnie wydawać teraz czas zacząć —
pierwszym krokiem jest utworzenie naszego grafu możesz to zrobić importując pakiet Pythona o nazwie rustworks, zdefiniuj ile
węzłów z niego korzystasz, określając liczbę n, następnie dodaj węzły do grafu G, będziesz też musiał
narysować krawędzie zrobimy to ręcznie, wypisując je w tablicy jak tutaj, gdzie pokazujesz ostatnią
liczbę, która określa wagę krawędzi lub jak silnie połączone są dwa określone węzły, tutaj po prostu
trzymamy się wagi jeden dla wszystkich, ale możesz się pobawić wagą później i zobaczyć jak zmienia się rozwiązanie
żeby lepiej zrozumieć co oznacza waga w tym kontekście, wróćmy do naszego przykładu z mediami społecznościowymi — możesz
traktować tę wagę jako to, jak wpływowa jedna osoba może być dla drugiej, twoje połączenie ze współmałżonkiem lub krewnym
na przykład prawdopodobnie dostałoby wyższą wagę niż ktoś, kto jest tylko znajomym, teraz narysuj swój graf —
dołączony samouczek pokaże ci właściwą składnię, zanim zastanowimy się jak
zmapować ten problem na Quantum circuit, zbudujmy pewien kontekst dotyczący tego, jak problem Max cut staje się problemem optymalizacyjnym
na początku rozważamy minimalizację funkcji f(x), gdzie wejście X to wektor
n-wymiarowy, którego składowe odpowiadają każdemu węzłowi grafu będziemy od teraz odwoływać się do tej funkcji jako
naszej funkcji kosztu, następnie musimy ograniczyć każdą z tych składowych do wartości zero lub
jeden, co oznacza po jednej lub drugiej stronie cięcia możemy napisać funkcję jako
parę węzłów x_i i x_j, która mówi nam czy odpowiednia krawędź jest w cięciu, zatem plus iloczyn x_i + x_j
minus x_i * x_j identyfikuje czy krawędź jest w cięciu, jeśli ta wartość jest równa
jeden, oznacza to że krawędź jest w cięciu, w przeciwnym razie jest zero i krawędź nie jest — problem znalezienia
maksymalnej liczby krawędzi w cięciu można wtedy sformułować jako maksymalizację tej funkcji, następnie
dodamy globalny znak minus do tej funkcji, dzięki czemu nowy problem będzie równoważny znalezieniu minimum tej funkcji
WEBVTT
zamiast tego, więc minimum f(x) w tym przypadku będzie wtedy gdy liczba krawędzi przechodzących przez cięcie jest
maksymalna, wybieramy sformułowanie tego problemu jako problemu minimalizacji, ponieważ pozwala nam to później zmapować go na problem
minimalizacji energii, czyli znalezienia stanu podstawowego, co jest tym, w czym komputery kwantowe są naturalnie naprawdę dobre
ale pamiętaj, że nie ma tu jeszcze nic związanego z Quantum Computing, wciąż musimy przeformułować ten problem na
coś, co komputer kwantowy może zrozumieć, jesteśmy teraz gotowi zabrać się do pracy i
pierwszym krokiem jest zmapowanie problemu na Quantum circuit, może nie być oczywiste jak
przejdziemy od grafu takiego jak ten, który właśnie narysowaliśmy, do Quantum circuit, ale weźmy to powoli — pamiętaj, że
będziemy próbować rozwiązać ten problem Max cut za pomocą qaoa, w algorytmie qaoa ostatecznie chcemy mieć operator
— hamiltonian, który będzie używany do reprezentowania funkcji kosztu naszego problemu, a także sparametryzowany
circuit — ansatz lub stan próbny, którego użyjemy do reprezentowania stanów kwantowych będących edukowanymi zgadywaniami lub kandydatami
na rozwiązanie problemu, możemy próbkować z tych stanów kandydujących i następnie oceniać je
za pomocą funkcji kosztu, w tym przypadku funkcja kosztu to f(x), ale musimy wyrazić ją w
sposób naturalny dla komputera kwantowego, w tym celu skorzystamy z szeregu matematycznych
transformacji, aby wyrazić f(x) jako funkcję energii — hamiltonian, pierwszym krokiem tego
procesu jest wyrażenie problemu minimalizacji f(x) jako kwadratowego nieograniczonego problemu optymalizacji binarnej
lub QUBO w skrócie, QUBO to ogólny sposób formułowania tych kombinatorycznych problemów optymalizacyjnych
tutaj Q jest macierzą N na N złożoną z liczb rzeczywistych, N odpowiada liczbie
węzłów w naszym grafie — pięć dla tego przykładu, a X to ten sam wektor zmiennych binarnych z pierwotnej
formulacji, aby efektywnie uruchomić algorytm qaoa, musimy wyrazić nasz problem optymalizacyjny w kategoriach
hamiltonianu, który jest operatorem matematycznym reprezentującym całkowitą energię układu, konkretnie chcemy
stworzyć hamiltonian funkcji kosztu posiadający właściwość, że jego energia stanu podstawowego lub minimalna wartość własna
odpowiada minimum funkcji kodującej maksymalną liczbę cięć na grafie G, gdy już mamy
ten hamiltonian, wszystko co musimy zrobić, aby rozwiązać nasz problem optymalizacyjny, to przygotowanie stanu podstawowego hamiltonianu na komputerze kwantowym, a następnie
próbkowanie z tego stanu z dużym prawdopodobieństwem da nam rozwiązanie minimalizacji f(x), jak się okazuje
mamy szczęście, ponieważ problem QUBO jest bardzo ściśle powiązany i właściwie obliczeniowo równoważny
jednemu z najbardziej znanych i wszechobecnych hamiltonianów w fizyce — hamiltonianowi Isinga, aby zapisać problem QUBO
jako ten hamiltonian Isinga, musimy tak naprawdę tylko dokonać prostej zamiany zmiennej, aby przejść z
zmiennych boolowskich 0 i 1 do zmiennych spinowych minus jeden i jeden, ten krok jest
prosty, jest pokazany bardziej szczegółowo w załączniku dołączonego notebooka dla zainteresowanych, ale ostatecznie minimalizacja tego wyrażenia QUBO
jest taka sama jak minimalizacja tego wyrażenia, przepisując ponownie nieco inaczej i
mamy nasz hamiltonian funkcji kosztu, gdzie minimum wyrażenia reprezentuje stan podstawowy, a Z
staje się operatorem Pauliego, podczas gdy B jest rzeczywistym skalarnym współczynnikiem, teraz gdy mamy nasz hamiltonian,
jest proste przepisanie go w kategoriach dwóch lokalnych operatorów ZZ Pauliego, które łatwo przekształcą się w
dwie bramki kubiczne w naszym Quantum circuit, zapoznaj się z dołączonym notebookiem, aby zobaczyć jak to jest zrobione, ale wynik
jest podany przez tę linię tutaj, zauważ, że w naszym przykładzie jest
sześć obiektów lub łańcuchów Pauliego, ponieważ każdy reprezentuje krawędź w grafie, długość łańcucha odpowiada liczbie
węzłów, więc I I I Z Z to pięć węzłów, a łańcuch będzie złożony z
tożsamości na wszystkich pozycjach z wyjątkiem indeksów węzłów zaangażowanych w krawędź, które będą miały wyrazy Z, w Qiskit
łańcuchy bitów reprezentujące qubity są indeksowane od końca, na przykład krawędź między węzłami 0 i 1 zostanie zakodowana jako
I I I Z Z, mając hamiltonian zapisany w kategoriach macierzy Pauliego, jesteśmy gotowi do zbudowania naszego
Quantum circuit, ten Quantum circuit pomoże nam próbkować dobre rozwiązania z komputera kwantowego, algorytm qaoa
jest inspirowany twierdzeniem adiabatycznym, które mówi, że jeśli zaczniemy w stanie podstawowym zależnego od czasu
hamiltonianu i jeśli hamiltonian ewoluuje wystarczająco wolno i ma wystarczająco dużo czasu, to końcowy stan będzie stanem podstawowym
końcowego hamiltonianu, qaoa można traktować jako dyskretną wersję Trottera kwantowego
algorytmu adiabatycznego, gdzie każdy krok Trottera reprezentuje warstwę, którą nazwiemy P, więc
zamiast ewoluować z jednego stanu do drugiego, w każdej warstwie P będziemy się przełączać tam i z powrotem między naszą funkcją
kosztu hamiltonianu a czymś zwanym hamiltonianem mixera, o którym usłyszymy więcej za chwilę, ale punkt, który chcę tu poruszyć,
polega na tym, że qaoa ma tę zaletę, że jest szybszy niż kwantowy algorytm adiabatyczny, ale zwraca przybliżone
rozwiązania zamiast optymalnych, w granicy gdzie liczba warstw dąży do nieskończoności, qaoa zbiega do przypadku adiabatycznego
ale oczywiście jest to obliczeniowo bardzo kosztowne, aby zbudować nasz Quantum circuit,
zastosujemy naprzemienne operatory sparametryzowane przez gamma i beta, które
będą reprezentować dyskretyzację ewolucji czasowej, więc znowu trzy główne części
circuit qaoa to: jeden — początkowy stan próbny w kolorze szarym, który jest stanem podstawowym
mixera z adiabatycznego stanu ewolucji, tworzonym przez zastosowanie Hadamard gate do każdego qubit, dwa —
ewolucja funkcji kosztu, którą już mamy w ciemnym fiolecie, i trzy — ewolucja pod hamiltonianem mixera,
której jeszcze nie omówiliśmy, w jasnym fiolecie, teraz nasz startowy hamiltonian jest
nazywany mixerem, ponieważ jego stan podstawowy jest superpozycją wszystkich możliwych łańcuchów bitów będących przedmiotem zainteresowania,
wymuszając w ten sposób mieszankę wszystkich możliwych rozwiązań na początku, hamiltonian mixera jest prostą sumą operacji Pauli X
na każdym węźle grafu, Qiskit pozwala na użycie innego niestandardowego operatora mixera jeśli chcesz, ale
w tym przypadku będziemy po prostu używać standardowego, więc jak widzisz, dzięki Qiskit wiele pracy jest
wykonywane za nas, dzięki czemu wymyślenie hamiltonianu mixera i stanu startowego staje się trywialne, jedyną pracą jaką musieliśmy wykonać to
znalezienie funkcji kosztu. Każda iteracja tych operatorów nazywana jest warstwą. Warstwy te można traktować jako
dyskretyzacje ewolucji czasowej układu, jak opisano wcześniej. Naprzemienny wzorzec pochodzi z
dekompozycji Trottera i przybliża funkcje wykładnicze nieprzemiennych macierzy. Ogólnie, im więcej warstw lub
kroków uwzględniamy, tym bliżej będziemy ciągłej ewolucji czasowej, więc teoretycznie wynik będzie dokładniejszy.
Ale w tym przykładzie zaczniemy od próbkowania z dwiema warstwami. Pamiętaj, że zarówno Hamiltonian funkcji kosztu, jak i
mikser są sparametryzowane — wciąż musimy wymyślić optymalne wartości dla gamma i
beta. Zdaję sobie sprawę, że to było dużo informacji i jeśli widzisz ten typ matematyki po raz pierwszy, może być trudno. Na szczęście jedną z świetnych
rzeczy w Qiskit jest to, że wiele z tego, co właśnie omówiliśmy, można zrobić automatycznie bez dużego nakładu pracy ze strony użytkownika. Dobrze rozumieć, co się
dzieje „pod maską", szczególnie gdy skalujemy do większych eksperymentów, ale nie będziesz musiał/a robić całej tej pracy
ręcznie za każdym razem. Odwzorowaliśmy teraz nasz problem na circuit kwantowy. To był trochę wysiłek,
ale nie martw się — staje się łatwiejsze i bardziej intuicyjne, im więcej razy to robisz. Jesteśmy teraz gotowi, aby przejść do kroku drugiego:
optymalizacji naszego circuit pod kątem sprzętu. Choć circuit, który właśnie stworzyliśmy, wygląda dość prosto i jest
przydatny do budowania intuicyjnego zrozumienia, pamiętaj, że chip kwantowy nie rozumie, co to jest ten zaabstrahowany
blok. Musimy go zamienić na serię jednoqUbitowych i dwuqubitowych bramek natywnych dla sprzętu. Gdy mówię
„natywnych", mam na myśli, że zostanie on przerobiony na to, co może być bezpośrednio wykonywane na qubitach. Takie circuit
są określane jako zapisane w architekturze zestawu instrukcji backend'u, co możesz widzieć jako circuit ISA.
Moduł transpilera Qiskit SDK oferuje serię przejść transpilacji, które mogą
wykonywać szeroką gamę transformacji circuit. Chcemy się upewnić, że nasz circuit jest zoptymalizowany dla naszego
celu. Przypomnij z poprzedniej lekcji, że proces transpilacji obejmuje kilka kroków: mapowanie
qubitów w circuit, czyli zmiennych decyzyjnych, na fizyczne qubity urządzenia; rozwijanie instrukcji
w circuit kwantowym do natywnych instrukcji sprzętu, które backend faktycznie rozumie; routing qubitów
w circuit, które bezpośrednio oddziałują, na fizyczne qubity będące sąsiadami ze sobą.
I jak zawsze, więcej szczegółów można znaleźć w dokumentacji.
Teraz nadchodzi ekscytujący krok — wybór backend'u, na którym uruchomimy nasz circuit. Faktycznie musimy to zrobić
przed krokiem transpilacji, ponieważ transpiler optymalizuje inaczej dla różnych procesorów. To jeszcze jeden powód, dla którego
ważne jest, że Qiskit może zautomatyzować tak wiele z tego etapu — nie chciałbyś/chciałabyś optymalizować swojego circuit ręcznie,
co można zrobić, ale czasem jest trudne i bardzo czasochłonne, tylko po to, żeby zdać sobie sprawę, że faktycznie chcesz uruchomić
swój circuit na innym procesorze o innych właściwościach i musisz robić całą tę pracę ponownie. Przekaż
swój wybrany backend przez funkcję transpilera i nie zapomnij określić swojego poziomu optymalizacji.
Tym razem wybrałem/wybrałam poziom optymalizacji trzy, który jest najwyższy i najbardziej wyczerpujący.
I to właściwie tyle dla kroku drugiego. Mój circuit został automatycznie stranspolowany i narysowałem/narysowałam go tutaj, żebyś
mógł/mogła zobaczyć, jak został przetłumaczony na jednoqUbitowe i dwuqubitowe bramki. Teraz nadszedł czas na krok trzeci:
uruchomienie circuit z prymitywami Qiskit. Dotychczas stranspolowaliśmy circuit, pozostawiając parametry gamma i
beta bez zmian, ale nie możemy faktycznie uruchomić circuit bez określenia wartości tych parametrów. W przepływie pracy
QAOA optymalne parametry QAOA są znajdowane w iteracyjnej pętli optymalizacji, gdzie uruchamiamy serię ewaluacji circuit
i używamy klasycznego optymalizatora do znalezienia optymalnych parametrów beta i gamma. Jednak musimy zacząć
od czegoś, dlatego zaimplementowałem/zaimplementowałam wstępne zgadywanki dla gamma 1, gamma 2, beta 1, beta 2 wynoszące pi/2 i pi
odpowiednio. Chcę też zaznaczyć, że użyjemy optymalizatora, żeby znaleźć lepsze rozwiązania dla gamma i beta.
Ponieważ obliczam tylko dwie warstwy, to wszystko czego potrzebuję, ale jeśli stworzysz dokładniejszy circuit QAOA,
uwzględnisz więcej warstw i będziesz potrzebować zoptymalizowanych gamma i beta dla każdej sekwencyjnej
warstwy. Zatrzymajmy się teraz na chwilę i przypomnijmy sobie nasze opcje dla prymitywów — mamy estymator i
sampler. Jak myślisz, którego użyjemy do tego rodzaju zadania? Niezależnie od tego, który wybierzesz,
masz rację — użyjemy obu: estymatora i samplera. Do wstępnej pętli optymalizacji
będziemy potrzebować estymatora, ale użyjemy samplera później do odczytania ostatecznego
rozwiązania. Teraz prawie jesteśmy gotowi do uruchomienia naszego algorytmu, obiecuję, ale bardzo szybko ważne jest, by wiedzieć, że możesz
wysłać swoje zadanie na różne sposoby, zwane trybami wykonania. Po pierwsze mamy tryb zadania — pojedyncze
żądanie prymitywu estymatora lub samplera, złożone bez menedżera kontekstu. Circuits i wejścia są pakowane jako
zunifikowane bloki prymitywów (PUB) i przesyłane jako zadanie do wykonania na komputerze
kwantowym. Tryb wsadowy to menedżer wielu zadań do wydajnego uruchamiania eksperymentu składającego się z zestawu
niezależnych zadań. Użyj trybu wsadowego do jednoczesnego przesyłania wielu zadań prymitywów. Tryb sesji — dedykowane
okno do uruchamiania wielozadaniowego obciążenia. Pozwala to użytkownikom premium eksperymentować z algorytmami wariacyjnymi w bardziej
przewidywalny sposób, a nawet jednoczesne uruchamianie wielu eksperymentów korzystając z równoległości
stosu. Używaj sesji dla iteracyjnych przepływów pracy i eksperymentów wymagających dedykowanego dostępu. Dla eksperymentu QAOA
sesja byłaby dobrym wyborem, jeśli masz do niej dostęp, ponieważ będziesz musiał/a wypróbować wiele circuit dla różnych wartości beta
i gamma. Wróćmy teraz do naszego problemu optymalizacji. Zdefiniowaliśmy już
Hamiltonian funkcji kosztu HC i pełny przepływ pracy jest następujący: algorytm QAOA
zaczyna od zainicjalizowania qubitów w stanie superpozycji, a następnie stosuje U_C z P warstwami.
Inicjalizuje parametry gamma i beta, a następnie uruchamia circuit za pomocą prymitywu estymatora. Gdy obliczymy
wartości oczekiwane, użyjemy optymalizatora SciPy o nazwie COBYLA. COBYLA
optymalizuje funkcję kosztu klasycznie poza QPU. Gdy te wartości gamma i beta zostaną zaktualizowane,
powtarzamy. Będziemy to robić, dopóki wartość całkowitej funkcji kosztu nie zbiegnie się i nie osiągnie najniższej wartości.
Następnie wybierzemy wartości gamma i beta odpowiadające tej najniższej wartości kosztu i uruchomimy circuit ostatni raz,
tym razem używając samplera. To jest wynik uruchomienia optymalizatora COBYLA z moimi wstępnymi zgadywankami. Możesz tu zobaczyć,
że wartość funkcji kosztu przez wykonywane iteracje zaczyna trochę chaotycznie — oscyluje w górę i w dół — ale
potem stabilizuje się na niskiej wartości. Użyjemy tych ostatnich wartości gamma i beta odpowiadających minimalnemu kosztowi
ewaluacji, aby uruchomić circuit po raz ostatni i spróbkować łańcuch bitów, który da nam
maksymalne cięcie. Używając naszych zoptymalizowanych wartości dla gamma i beta, uruchomimy circuit po raz ostatni, aby znaleźć najlepszy
możliwy łańcuch bitów za pomocą samplera. Podałem/podałam konkretne wartości, których używam tutaj, ale pamiętaj, że gdy
spróbujesz tego samemu/samej lub nawet ponownie uruchomisz ten sam notatnik tutorialowy, wartości te mogą się nieznacznie zmienić. Teraz uruchomimy
nasz zoptymalizowany circuit z tymi wartościami i znajdziemy nasze kandydackie rozwiązanie problemu Max Cut. Jeśli korzystałeś/korzystałaś z
sesji, nie jest to już konieczne, ponieważ właśnie uruchamiamy ostatnie zadanie. Teraz wreszcie spojrzymy na
etap przetwarzania końcowego i znalezienia naszego ostatecznego rozwiązania. Najpierw wykreślmy wszystkie
możliwe kombinacje węzłów, które przekształciliśmy w łańcuchy bitów, jako histogram. Możesz od razu zobaczyć, że
kiedy uruchomiłem/uruchomiłam, znalazłem/znalazłam cztery rozwiązania i wyróżniłem/wyróżniłam te w kolorze fioletowym, które są bardziej prawdopodobne niż jakiekolwiek inne rozwiązanie.
Najwyższy, a więc najbardziej prawdopodobny łańcuch bitów to 0 1 0 1. Zwróć uwagę na kolejność qubitów
— jest odwrócona na wykresie. Patrząc na najbardziej prawdopodobne rozwiązanie, zauważamy, że węzły 0 i 3 są zgrupowane razem
i podobnie węzły 1, 2 i 4. Możemy wreszcie wykreślić najbardziej prawdopodobny
łańcuch bitów z powrotem jako graf i pamiętaj, że łańcuch bitów po prostu odpowiada numerom węzłów i temu, czy są uwzględnione
— oznaczone jedynką — lub nieuwzględnione — oznaczone zerem — w naszym grupowaniu. Gdy rysujemy cięcie, możemy zobaczyć na własne oczy
przybliżoną linię dla najlepszego cięcia, która po prostu reprezentuje idealne grupowanie wszystkich pięciu węzłów — narysowałem/narysowałam ją tutaj.
Chcę jednak spędzić trochę czasu na omówieniu faktu, że prawidłowe rozwiązanie nie jest unikalne.
Ze względu na symetrię tego grafu istnieje wiele prawidłowych rozwiązań. Zamiast węzłów 0 i 3
wewnątrz cięcia, moglibyśmy mieć węzły 2 i 4 i widzisz, że musiałem/musiałam tylko obrócić moje cięcie, aby
uwzględnić te nowe punkty. To rozwiązanie pięciu pozostaje takie samo.
Spójrzmy jeszcze raz przez chwilę na histogram i cztery najbardziej prawdopodobne rozwiązania. Ostatnie dwa rozwiązania to te,
które właśnie wykreśliliśmy i są równie poprawne, ale to nie wszystko — moglibyśmy też odwrócić kolorowanie dla wszystkich
prawidłowych rozwiązań i tym razem po prostu myśleć o węzłach jako byciu wewnątrz kontra na zewnątrz cięcia. Na
poprzednim slajdzie zidentyfikowaliśmy dwa unikalne prawidłowe rozwiązania, ale w rzeczywistości są jeszcze dwa — po jednym odpowiadającym
odwrotności każdego z tych. Patrz tutaj, gdzie narysowałem/narysowałam pozostałe dwa rozwiązania — po prostu odwróciłem/odwróciłam
kolory. Jedynym problemem jest to, że algorytm faktycznie nie znalazł ani nie zidentyfikował tego czwartego ostatniego rozwiązania jako
jednego z czterech najbardziej prawdopodobnych odpowiedzi. Było na piątym miejscu. Czwarte rozwiązanie, które algorytm zidentyfikował,
jest w rzeczywistości nieprawidłowe i gdybyś je narysował/narysowała, zobaczyłbyś/zobaczyłabyś, że to rozwiązanie ma tylko cztery cięcia, a ponieważ inne
mają pięć, a cztery jest wyraźnie mniej niż pięć, to oczywiście błędne. Sedno tego
jest takie, że to jest algorytm przybliżony — nie jest nieomylny i nie jest poprawny 100% czasu. Musisz
zastosować własną wiedzę i zrozumienie, aby zdrowo sprawdzić rozwiązania. Warto podkreślić, że
ten błąd może wynikać z kilku miejsc: może to być przybliżony charakter samego algorytmu i mała
liczba warstw, które wybrałem/wybrałam. Może to być błąd skończonego próbkowania, który można by zmniejszyć przez zwiększenie
liczby strzałów w moim eksperymencie, lub może to być błąd odczytu, ponieważ czwarte prawdziwe rozwiązanie różni się tylko o jeden
bit. Powód, dla którego wskazuję wszystkie te możliwości, jest taki, że tego wymaga pełne stanie się
praktykiem informatyki kwantowej. Musisz rozumieć wydajność sprzętu i to, jak może to przyczyniać się
do pewnych typów błędów i jak je korygować. Nie zapomnijmy jednak, że
było 32 możliwych rozwiązań w postaci łańcuchów bitów i że cztery prawdziwe rozwiązania znalazły się w pięciu najlepszych
kandydatach, a użyłem/użyłam tylko dwóch warstw, żeby to znaleźć. Ogólnie, chcąc zwiększyć szanse na znalezienie
najlepszego Max Cut za każdym razem, zwiększyłbym/zwiększyłabym głębokość warstwy. Są pewne subtelności w tym, ale to na późniejszy
odcinek. Teraz pozwolę ci spróbować tego samemu/samej, ale tym razem użyjesz 100
qubitów. Jeśli więc zaczniemy od narysowania naszego grafu 100 qubitów, możesz zobaczyć, że nie jest już proste ani nawet możliwe
ocenić wzrokiem, gdzie wystąpiłoby maksymalne cięcie. Jest po prostu zbyt wiele możliwości, żeby wskazać je ręcznie, ale
rozwiązanie tego problemu za pomocą QAOA jest wciąż całkowicie wykonalne i możesz postępować według dokładnie tego samego przepływu pracy, którego użyliśmy dla 5
qubitów. Zaraz wyślę cię na własne poszukiwania i zlecę ci wykonanie tego eksperymentu, ale zanim to zrobię,
podsumujmy. Pamiętaj, że sześć kroków dowolnego zadania QAOA jest następujących: jeden — definiowanie
Hamiltonianu kosztu takiego, że jego stan podstawowy koduje rozwiązanie problemu optymalizacyjnego; dwa — definiowanie
Hamiltonianu miksera; trzy — konstruowanie operatorów odpowiadających wykładnikowanym
Hamiltonianom; cztery — budowanie circuit, który składa się z początkowego stanu podstawowego miksera i naprzemiennych
powtarzanych warstw funkcji kosztu i ewolucji pod Hamiltonianem miksera; pięć — przygotowanie stanu początkowego i
użycie klasycznych technik obliczeniowych do optymalizacji parametrów; sześć — uruchomienie circuit, zmierzenie wyjściowych łańcuchów bitów
szukając najbardziej prawdopodobnego rozwiązania. Kilka uwag: użyłem/użyłam
poziomu optymalizacji trzy dla mojego przykładu z 5 qubitami, ale może to nie było konieczne i prawidłowa odpowiedź mogłaby
być zwracana przez większość czasu na niższym poziomie optymalizacji, ponieważ głębokość circuit była dość niska dla przypadku 5
qubitów. Ale dla 100 qubitów i dużej głębokości circuit prawie na pewno będziesz potrzebować najwyższego poziomu
optymalizacji, aby znaleźć właściwą odpowiedź. Pamiętaj też, że jedną z najtrudniejszych części typowego przepływu pracy
w skali użytkowej jest etap mapowania i znalezienie grafu dobrze odpowiadającego topologii heavy hex IBM. Gdybyś
robił/robiła tę pracę od zera, bez wątpienia tu poświęciłbyś/poświęciłabyś większość czasu. Na razie ta część została
zrobiona za ciebie, bo to nie jest główny punkt tego ćwiczenia, ale miej na uwadze, że jest to coś, co
będzie wymagać ćwiczenia, a uruchamianie zadania na dużą skalę nie zawsze jest proste. Zagłębimy się w to
bardziej w odcinku 4. Twój ostateczny circuit będzie oczywiście wyglądał znacznie bardziej niechlujnie niż circuit, który uruchomił się na 5 qubitach,
ale z drugiej strony patrzenie na ten circuit i widzenie, ile bramek ma, i wiedząc, że
masz możliwość faktycznego uruchomienia tego na prawdziwych procesorach kwantowych, jest całkiem
imponujące. I to było moje ostateczne rozwiązanie — możesz zobaczyć, że algorytm jest z pewnością zdolny do grupowania tych
węzłów w dwie grupy, rzekomo identyfikując najlepsze Max Cut, które je dzieli, przechodząc od dwóch zestawów
do samej linii Max Cut. Jest to trywialne — wszędzie gdzie kolor zmienia się wzdłuż linii łączących węzły, wyznacza to
miejsce, gdzie powinna być narysowana linia Max Cut. Kiedy uruchomiłem/uruchomiłam, wartość Max Cut, którą udało mi się osiągnąć, wynosi
84. Spróbuj więc sam/sama i daj mi znać, czy osiągniesz coś podobnego w komentarzach. Wypróbuj trzy warstwy, może cztery,
spróbuj zmienić wagi między węzłami i sprawdź, jak zmienia to wynik. Jest dużo ciekawych eksperymentów,
które możemy przeprowadzać z QAOA. Pamiętaj, że nie ma gwarancji, że właśnie znalazłem/znalazłam najlepsze możliwe
rozwiązanie. Wiemy, że to dobre rozwiązanie, ale dla zabawy rzucam ci wyzwanie — spróbuj mnie pobić. Sprawdź, czy możesz uzyskać coś
lepszego niż 84. Podsumowując: QAOA to bardzo dynamiczny
algorytm i jest wiele heurystyk i dużo do odkrycia. Daje dużo miejsca na uczenie się nowych
rzeczy o dziedzinie optymalizacji w ogóle. Ostatnio ukazało się wiele prac w przestrzeni optymalizacji,
czego dowodem są wszystkie prace arXiv, które ostatnio pojawiły się online na temat QAOA lub optymalizacji. I co jest
naprawdę fajne, to że w końcu nie wszystkie te prace to prace teoretyczne. Teoretycy studiowali i badali
QAOA przez lata, ale teraz zaangażowali się eksperymentatorzy, ponieważ w końcu mamy sprzęt
taki jak procesory IBM, które są zdolne do uruchamiania wielu z tych eksperymentów. Przechodzimy z przestrzeni wyobraźni
do świata rzeczywistego i to jest bardzo ekscytujące. Tak, jest jeszcze dużo pracy do wykonania i wciąż jest
wiele błędów, z którymi musimy sobie poradzić, ale robimy szybkie postępy, a ty oglądasz/oglądasz to
wideo — jeśli dotarłeś/dotarłaś tak daleko — jesteś zdolny/zdolna do samodzielnego uruchamiania tych eksperymentów. Idź i spróbuj uruchomić swój własny
eksperyment z 100 qubitami i daj nam znać, jak poszło. Postępuj zgodnie z tutorialem, a będziesz w dobrych rękach. I jeśli
masz jakieś pytania lub utkniesz, nie martw się — wszyscy tak czuliśmy lub mieliśmy te same pytania, gdy zaczynaliśmy
się uczyć. Daj z siebie wszystko, daj nam znać, jakie pytania napotkasz, i do zobaczenia następnym razem.
[Muzyka]